So as we ended last time,
we said despite Erin Shaw,
which says you can't have
these Lewis structures might,
they're really be shared
pair bonds and lone pairs.
And how do we know we
have to look or feel?
So the last time we tried feeling
with scanning probe microscopy,
AFM STM snob there are really great,
you can see atoms,
you can see molecules,
but you can't see bonds.
Okay,
so what's the key word here?
Luxe, right? So maybe we'll
see it if we can't feel it.
Now this is the entrance to this building,
the old delivery entrance
out on prospect street.
And you know there's interesting stuff
all over the building. Up here on the top,
there's a fluted filter
paper and a funnel,
but hidden back in the
shadows is something that's
a little surprising to you
back there,
which is a microscope.
What science do you associate that
with biology and not chemistry,
right? What's it doing? Well, at
least it's back in the shadows,
but maybe the eyeball up there says
we can see the things we can't feel.
Okay, here's a, this is a picture.
Does anybody recognize this?
When it came from.
It's from Robert Hooks.
Great Book Micrographia from 1665.
It's a wonderful book.
It's a page.
The page is about this big.
And imagine the people who had fleas
seeing that for the first time.
It's exquisite. This, this a
drawing and he said in the book,
but nature is not to be limited
by our narrow comprehension.
Future improvements of glasses may yet
further enlighten our understanding and
ocular inspection may demonstrate that
which is yet we may think too extravagant
either to feign or to suppose.
So if he had a microscope
that could do that in 1665,
we must have a microscope.
Now that's powerful enough to see bonds.
Right?
And in fact,
we do,
in fact there's a brand new one that's
that they promise will come online next
Tuesday in a room about a
hundred yards over that way. Uh,
and but,
and that,
the trick it uses is the same one Hook
Newton used to measure the distance of
the air gap for Newton's rings or
that Hook explained by the pulses,
right? And it's interference
that comes from scattering.
So you've seen oil on water,
thin layers of oil on water,
and you see rainbows in them. Why? Okay,
so light comes in and scatters from
two surfaces that let's say our 200
nanometers apart.
Okay?
So the path difference between the one
that reflects from the top and the one
that reflects from the bottom,
the difference is 400 nanometers.
One goes 400 and the meters
further than the other.
Now suppose that happened
to be one wavelength, right?
Then if that purple light that came
in one going further than the other,
they would come out
exactly one wave apart.
So it would be as if it were a single way,
but they would reinforce one another and
you'd see the purple lights strongly.
Okay? But if the wavelength
difference where it half we're,
we're, we're half. If the path
difference, we're half the wavelength,
like for Red Light.
Oh,
what did we do here?
Elaine?
Better get it quick or something comes up.
You're a good sport.
Okay, thank you. Okay, so here we go.
If it's one wavelength path difference,
then it reinforces and we got a
nice strong way of coming out.
But if it's half a wavelength difference,
like for the red light,
then they cancel. One is a maximum one,
the other's a minimum and there's zero.
Okay,
so you get no scattering.
So that's why you get different colors
because the oil is different thicknesses
in different parts of the slick.
Okay,
so here's the new machine that's right
over here that's supposed to come out,
do machines. Actually there are
two of them. It was a package deal.
And that's Chris.
I in car veto,
who's the director of the
chemical instrumentation
center and the proud owner of
these two new machines.
So the one he's looking at there is
a user op is to be operated by users.
So it's just you sort of pushed buttons
and you get where the atoms are in the
molecule, right? At least that's the hope.
And it costs about $200,000 okay,
so there's a little thread
there that has a crystal on,
but you need a magnifying glass to see it.
You won't see it with your eyes.
It's a tiny, tiny crystal. Okay. So the,
here's the x Ray tube rays,
come down the pipe there,
hit the crystal and get scattered
and are detected by this CCD detector
dirt.
Okay?
And then from that information,
those scattered rays,
you get where the atoms
are in the molecule more
precisely as you'll see where
the electrons are in the
molecule or in the crystal.
The other machine that he is
especially proud of cost 350 k.
And why is it more expensive?
Because it collects more.
Instead of using that
little disk of a CCD,
it has a curved image plate,
right?
So when the x rays come down
here and hit the tiny crystal,
many more of them get collected by
the plate. So it's more efficient.
Okay?
So those will be coming soon.
And if all you have to do is press a
button and the structure comes out,
that seems fine. But that's not the
goal of this course. The press a button.
We want to understand
how such a thing works.
Seeing individual molecules,
atoms, maybe bonds,
there's a problem.
And the problem is wavelength.
Because you know,
if in principle you can't resolve
things that are closer together than the
wavelength of light.
And the wavelength of light we've been
talking about here is 400 800 nanometers.
Whereas how, what's the distance
of a carbon carbon bond?
Anybody remember one and a
half angst drummers, right?
So three orders of magnitude smaller
than the wavelength of light.
So this is a problem and
it's why as you'll see,
you use rays because they
have short wavelength.
Now to understand this, we'd have to
know what light is. So what is light?
You people have studied physics and so on.
So what's like Wilson? Who knows? Okay?
It's an electromagnetic wave.
Okay,
now I've seen deed. It is,
I've seen waves on the ocean,
right?
Does it mean that the electromagnetic
waves are like those waves?
In what way is an
electromagnetic wave a wave?
What's wavy about it?
Well,
you can make a graph that's
a wave that involves light.
So here what we're going to plot
is the force on a charge, right?
The charges is a particular position.
We'll have the charge over there
on the right. It's fixed there.
And we're gonna measure the force on it.
That'll make it accelerate up or down.
Okay. And it'll go. And if you have hopes,
this doesn't work quite the way it
does on mine, you please let me know.
And things like that happen anyhow. Oh
No, maybe it's going to work. Oh No,
I see what happened. Yeah. Okay. Uh, what
that first thing did was went up and down,
up and down. Up and down. Okay.
But if you plot a thin as a function
of time, it's a, it's a wave,
right?
The field at a particular point as a
function of time is a way it goes up then
down then up and down. Okay. Now,
so what we plot the field or the force
on a charge at one position as a function
of time.
But there's another way of making a
plot that also shows light as a wave,
which is the show the field at
different places at the same time.
Right? So we're going to change it. And
now the horizontal axis is the position,
but it's at a particular instant.
So as the thing goes along,
there are different forces
at different positions. Okay.
And that again,
that will be a wave.
So that's the sense in which
light is a wave light is.
And what is it that that we're plotting,
we're plotting the electric field.
So light is associated with an electric
field that goes up and down, right?
And you can plot it in time
or in space and get away.
So that's the sense in which it's a way,
it's also incidentally a magnetic field.
It's electromagnetic that Maxwell
dealt with, things like that.
And there's a magnetic field
perpendicular to the electric field,
but we don't care about it,
at least not until next semester when we
talk about a nuclear magnetic resonance,
because the electric field is
so much stronger in its effect,
dog molecules on now it's effect
is on charges on electrons,
on protons. Okay. Therefore on nuclei now,
accelerated electrons scatter light.
So here comes the light in.
We'll see if this works.
Okay.
So it makes the,
it makes the electron go up
and down as the light goes by.
But up and down,
moving of electron excelerator
electrons is what creates electric fee.
Put creates electric fields,
right? That's what an antenna is,
is electrons moving back and forth.
So when the original light comes
through and hits the electron,
make it vibrate up and down,
right?
That Electron vibrating emits radiation,
electromagnetic radiation in
all directions, all directions,
except this direction and stronger.
The more you're perpendicular to the
direction and slow going up and down.
But anyhow,
it scatters the light.
So most of the lights still
goes through the direct beam,
but a little bit of it gets scattered.
Much less would be scattered.
I've been a single electron
wouldn't scatter very much.
You need lots of electrons to scattered
a lot and they have to be cooperating.
Okay,
now you tell me,
why are we interested in
electron scattering light?
They're just as many protons in
a sample as there are electrons.
Why don't we worry about the
Proton scattering the light?
So what
the electrons are,
what moves you need the movie in charge
to generate the scattered light. The, the,
the, the, the lightest,
a positive charge things
are uh, I mean, uh,
abnormal particles are thousand
times heavier than electrons,
so they don't move very much.
It's the electrons that scatter the light.
So with x rays, you see
electrons, not nuclei,
okay, they're too heavy now then,
but then you need a lot of electrons to
scatter enough to see and they have to
cooperate, right? So here
we have ripples on a pond.
You've also seen,
you've all seen that kind of thing
with a little bit of rain falling.
And so suppose you had two spots that
are generating ripples to electrons,
let's say.
And they give off a circular waves here
in two dimensions and they interfere
with one another. But you can see a
pattern is emerging and when you're very,
very far away from these compared to
the distance between the electrons as
indeed you are in these samples were
talking about where you have an infinite
testable crystal and the detector played
is a substantial distance away, right?
The electrons are really close to
one another. Uh, so you're way, way,
way far away on the scale of the
distance between the electrodes. Okay?
And now you can see what pattern there
is for high points and low points for
waves.
Okay?
Cause you can see here that there's a
pattern like that that goes along the
Maxima.
Everybody see that?
And halfway in between those
days, those days, yellow lines,
there's no change at all.
Nothing's happening there,
right? And if you go out very,
very far away, you can see that
as some topically these approach,
these straight lines that
originate between the electrons
or on the crystal in a
real case.
So what you have coming out of the
crystal are straight rays of light.
Ex-Ray light,
okay.
And the angles at which they come out
depend on where the electrons are.
The electrons are closer together or
further apart or displaced in this
direction. You'll get different
patterns of the ripples.
So somehow it must be possible or
there must be a connection between the
positions of the electrons and
where are these rays are coming out,
right?
And if you can go backwards to go from
where the rain has come out to where the
electrons were, then you've
solved the problem, right?
You're not creating an image the way
you would with a normal microscope.
You're trying to to
interpret the scattering.
So the angular intensity distribution at
great distance depends on the scatterer
distribution at the origin
that is in the crystal. Now,
if you have normal light and a
lens like Hooke's microscope,
then that you can use
these lenses to refocus it.
So the same information is coming out.
The sample there is emitting these rays,
but lens collects them and refocuses
them to make an enlarged image that you
then observe.
Right?
The problem is that you
can't do that with x-rays.
People are making efforts
now with nanofabrication
kind of things to make things
that will act like lenses for
X-ray's and they've made some steps,
but nothing like you would need to
actually observe electrons in the crystal.
Okay. Be sure to read. There's a
webpage if some of you read it so far,
that has to do with what I'm lecturing on
now, which will help you a lot I think.
So look for that.
So we're interested in seeing molecules,
atoms, bonds collectively
by x Ray crystallography.
That is,
we're not seeing the image
of individual electrons.
We're seeing the scattering that comes
from all the electrons acting together,
so we're not seeing them one at the time.
We're seeing something collective
about them so that for example,
a real sample or a sort of fake sample
of benzene which had a bunch of carp,
six carbon atoms in a ring might
look like this at any given time.
It's sort of regular,
but things are a little bit one way
or the other vibrating and so on.
Okay.
Now you wouldn't see this in x-ray
because everything is cooperating in what
you're getting.
You'd see some sort of average of all
of them and it would be a little bit
smeared because of that.
Right?
You don't see an issue with scanning
probe microscopy with these sharp tips.
You actually can feel individual Adams,
and if one atom is someplace else,
you'll see it, you'll feel it
there. That's not true. An X ray,
you see an averaged structure
and it's averaged in two ways.
There's blurring from
motion and from defects.
There's one benzine
molecule missing there.
It's time average because it
took you time to collect these,
this information with synchrotrons
and really, really intense, uh, beams.
People are trying to get faster
and faster data collection,
but still what you see as time averaged
on the scale of how fast the atoms are
moving in your sample.
So it's time averaged what you
get and it's also space averaged,
right? It's as if you put them
all on top of one another.
That's what you would see.
But some are displaced a little
one way or the other and so on.
So it's a little fuzzy.
Okay.
And that this is an advantage
for scanning probe microscopy,
which operates in real space, actually
feels individual things. Okay.
So x rays were discovered in 1895 by
Redken using cruxes tube that we talked
about.
Okay.
He took a picture of his wife's hand
there for our rent goods hand in 1896 but
what do you see is,
is not a picture that you can blow up
like with a microscope because it's just a
shadow.
It's all this.
All the bones do is stop the x rays
that are going through so you don't get
something that's enlarged,
right?
You're not going to be able to use it
the way you use medical x-rays. Okay,
but in 1912 marksman Laowei
invented ex-ray diffraction,
right? Which is the scattering and
detect, not trying to focus things,
not using a shadow,
but looking at these rays that come
out and try to figure out from them
something about what the outcomes were.
And that's his diffraction picture.
That's what you'd see on that.
Remember there was that round CCD
plate that's on this new machine.
You might get a pattern that
looked sort of like that.
That was copper sulfate in 1912 but
the real breakthrough was by William
Lawrence Burns,
who was 22 years old.
He had just graduated
from Cambridge University.
When he determined the structure of a
crystal using Lowery's X-ray diffraction
pattern. So he figured out how to
go the other way to go from the,
from the x-rays scattered pattern to
what the Adams were that we're doing it
right.
And he did this in 1912 when he was 22
years old and he got the Nobel prize in
1915 he's still the youngest
Nobel laureate. Right?
His son gave me permission
to use this picture.
It was very nice guy lives in Cambridge.
Okay.
Then of course we've come
a long way from that.
I think you probably recognize
this picture, right? What is it?
It's the scattering from Da.
Is it a picture of DNA?
No,
it's not a double helix.
What it is is the way X-ray's come out
when they hit the double helix and you
have to figure backwards and that's what
Couric was able to do and we'll discuss
how he did that.
Okay.
So that's 1952 40 years
after brags discovery.
And then in just in 2000 not so long ago,
this has gone to the complete structure
of the ribosomes at 2.4 Ostrom's write a
resolution, which was done here at Yale
in this building and the next building.
Okay?
And that's what it looks like.
It has 25 nanometers across 250 on strums.
As long as whatever number that is,
lots of carbon carbon bonds.
And you see all those atoms there are
greater than 100,000 Adam's not counting
the hydrogens,
incidentally.
Why is it easier to see other
atoms then to see hydrogens?
Because that's where the electrons are.
Hydrogens come with only one electron.
Other items come with lots of electrons.
So it's hard to see hydrogens much
easier to see the other things. Okay,
now what can electron diffraction
show x ray to fraction show?
That's what we want to know.
Can it show molecules? Yeah.
Can it show Adams?
Apparently I just showed you a picture.
But what we really want to know is whether
it can show bonds and whether Lewis
was right.
So to understand this,
we have to know how diffraction works.
Oh,
you could just be like the people that
are going punch the button on that
machine, but that's not what I think
you wouldn't be satisfied with.
So I'll help you out.
Yeah,
so like all right, x rays or
waves, they just are very short.
So now I'm going to demonstrate
with a machine here,
which was designed for an
overhead projector, but I
believe it's gonna work here.
Okay,
so here are waves.
Okay.
So here's a wave coming in,
okay?
And when it gets to this position, it
hits an electron here on an electron here.
Forget this one from now. Okay?
Everybody got me at a given time.
This,
the,
these two electrons are being pushed up
that they're going to be pushed down as
this wave passes by. Okay? Now as
those two get pushed up and down,
they give off waves in
almost all directions,
all directions for our purposes.
Okay?
So they give off waves in all
different directions. Right?
Now notice the one, the,
the,
the part of that scattered x-ray that
goes straight forward in the same
direction,
the original light came in is bound
to be in phase with one another,
right? And we can test that
with this line here, right?
Because if they're going right,
straight ahead,
this one is a maximum when
this one is a maximum.
Everybody with me on
that and it'll keep that.
So you'll get scattering by
both of them cooperating,
coming out if it's straight ahead.
But how about if it's at an angle?
Okay, so I can push this up and change
the angle. How about at that angle?
How much light is going to be coming
out from the, from these two electrons?
None. They exactly
cancel each other, right?
But if I go to this angle now, they're
just as strong as they were originally,
right? And then it'll go weak, weak, weak,
weak or weakest, nothing. Then stronger,
stronger, stronger, stronger,
very strong, weak or weaker,
weaker, weaker, weaker, zero.
So there'll be a modular as you go out
at different angles here going either up
or down,
it'll be strong.
Then we then nothing then strong than
nothing strong than nothing. Right.
So now what will determine
what will determine how reg,
how frequently these angles recur
at which reinforcement occurs?
Is that clear? The question?
What determines the angles?
Yeah. Pardon me. Obviously the waypoints.
What if the way boys were
very, very, very short,
then you'd get lots of,
you wouldn't have to move very much
before the next one came in. Right?
If they were very good. What
else determines it? Besides
the wavelength? Yeah, John,
the distance. That's what we're
really interested in is using this.
No way in the wavelength of the
x-rays using this to measure distance.
Okay. Now let's forget the one on the
bottom here. Let's put this one in.
Okay. Now, okay, for reference,
let's look at the bottom of a second.
So the first reinforcement came here
between the top one and the bottom one.
Everybody with me? How about for
the top one in the middle one?
Where did the first one come?
You had to go to a higher angle there
to get reinforcement between the top in
the middle. Right? So the
closer things are together,
the fewer the angles are
everybody with me on that?
Notice that's a reciprocal relationship.
The closer things are in
what we call real space.
The distance between the electrons,
the further apart are the rays
that come out in angle, okay?
So it's backwards.
Closer together,
further apart in what's
called reciprocal space, okay?
Now suppose you had a whole row of
electrons that were evenly spaced.
Okay, so here's the first, the second, the
third. Now we'll take all three of them,
right?
And what you notice is that as that,
as we go out, it gets weaker,
weaker, weaker, weaker,
weaker, weaker, weaker, weaker.
We here.
Now when we get to the angle here,
where are the first and the third
were very strong. What do we see now?
The one in the middle
cancels the first one,
and if we're a very long row of them,
the fourth one would camp this here.
The second one cancels the first one,
the fourth would cancel the third, the
sixth would cancel the fifth and so on.
And you wouldn't get anything,
right?
But then you'd get it again
when you got to the second,
the one that would have been the
second row, the second angle,
if it was just one in three,
right.
We'll be strong because this one halfway
in between we'll, we'll reinforce, right?
So closer together or further apart.
And if you have a whole row
of equally spaced things,
they'll all be together according to
whatever the distance between successive
ones is. Yes. Shy what the
cause electrons to be
spaced. Exactly. Evenly
crystal x Ray crystallography. Right?
So that's why you use crystals.
Okay.
That's what we want to say
here. I think. So let me
turn that off for now.
There we go.
Now if I can handle this thing,
there we go.
That good.
Okay.
So that's the wave machine.
And if you want to do it in
the privacy of your room,
you can go to this website at stony brook
and download something that allows you
to run a Java applet that does
sort of this kind of thing.
Uh, this, if you blow it up in there,
the waves look sort of
funny there at the Adams.
And the reason is because you're
majoring the the phase perpendicular to
different directions of the wave.
That's just to help you
out if you'd try this and,
and have and are confused by that.
Okay.
Now there are, so suppose you have
just an arbitrary set of electrons
and the waves coming in and hitting them.
What directions will you
get reinforcement in? Well,
there are two directions that you're
guaranteed no matter what the spacing is.
Okay? And that's this. Here comes
the here, the light comes in
and goes out.
So the direct beam,
you have the same path because one of
them gets hit earlier but has a longer
path coming out and the
other one gets hit later.
But it has a shorter path coming out.
So they're guaranteed to be exactly in
phase if they're scattering straight
ahead.
Okay?
But only a little of the
light is getting scattered.
Most of it is the direct
beam. So you don't even notice
the difference from that.
So that's not very exciting.
But there's another angle at which your
sure that these two are going to be in
phase. And that's this angle. Now,
how do we get to that angle? Uh, I,
I've lost some of the, uh,
since you downloaded that,
there's some more stuff in here now,
but uh, so now I can't quite remember.
Let me just try. Okay, so this is,
this blue line here is called
the scattering vector and
that's how different the
Arrow coming out is from
the Arrow going in, right?
That's just the funny mathematical or
geometric thing that people have defined.
They call it the scattering
vector. Right? Now, this,
this length is exactly
the same as that link.
This link is exactly the same as that leg.
And when you turn it a given angle,
those two will,
the vector between those
will be perpendicular to
the direction they're going
and they'll be in phase again,
right?
And if you draw the line
that connects the two points,
right? Notice the scattering vector
is perpendicular to that line.
So you say that,
that,
that this incoming wave was
scattered perpendicular to the,
to this line.
That's how a mirror works.
The things that are in that,
that,
that angle is called the specular angle.
Cause speculum is the
Latin word for mirror,
right?
So, so, so you're,
you're bound to get reinforcement at the
specular angle and you know that from
having looked at mirrors,
okay?
Now suppose there were another
electron on that same line or plane,
okay? For the same reason,
it's guaranteed to be in phase.
So everything on that plane will scatter
in phase at that particular angle.
They'll all reinforce one another.
So all electrons on a plane perpendicular
to the scattering vector scatter in
phase at the specular angle.
Now suppose you have a whole bunch of
electrons and you have to figure out how
they're going to reinforce or cancel one
another. There's a trick you can use.
You see if you can discern a set
of planes that are evenly spaced,
that contain almost all or almost all
of the electrons you're interested in.
Okay?
Now if you look at this pattern,
you can see that there's a set of planes
equally spaced that passes through all
of them.
Can you perceive it
there?
Okay,
there are three electrons on the
first plane, four on the second,
two on the third,
one on the fourth.
Okay.
Now, why is that handy? Okay,
so there's the scattering vector
perpendicular to these planes and all the
electrons on any one plane.
We'll scatter in phase with one another.
Okay, so, so it's as if there were a
single electron three times bigger, right?
Or four or two or a one on those success
a planes because they're all going to
be in phase with one another.
So we could pretend they're all
at one point on any given plane.
Okay,
so now all we have to worry about is
the phase relationship from one plane to
the next.
Fixed at that.
Yeah.
If they were in phase from one plane
to the next as well as on the planes,
then everything will be in phase.
You'll get really bright reflection
coming out of that scattering angle.
Okay.
Now,
so let's think of,
so it's as if we had these collected
electrons all lying on the scatter in
vector and we want to know whether
they're in phase with one another. Okay?
So here's light that comes in and out
at a certain angle from the first one,
three electrons worth of scattering from
that. The ones that were on that plane.
Okay.
And four from the second plane.
Now are the three and the four
in phase with one another.
What condition would have to apply in
order for those to be in phase with one
another?
They have different path lengths,
but if the paths differ by an
integral number of wavelengths,
then they'll be in phase with
one another and reinforce, okay,
so there's the path difference in red.
If that happens to be
suppose the wavelength of the
light and the angle of the
scattering, which Oh, also
determines that path differences.
You can see suppose that the wavelength
and the angle are such that that happens
to be one wavelength. Okay, so
those are in phase with one another.
All seven will be scattering together.
Right.
How about the next one with two electrons?
How about its phase?
What was the condition we
talked about up here at the top?
Evenly spaced.
So what do you know about the next one?
It's going to be in phase two
two ways behind the first one,
right? It'll be two wavelengths behind
the first one. Exactly. At some angle.
Right? And the next one will
be three wavelengths behind.
So all these electrons are going to be
scattering in phase at that particular
angle. So you get a really strong
reflection coming out, right?
It'll be as if it were all the angle,
all the electrons working together.
So the net in phase scattering is 10
as if there were 10 electrons doing the
scattering.
That's great.
Right now suppose that the first
path difference instead pose,
you had a different wavelength
or a different angle.
So the first between
the three and the four,
suppose the difference in
path was half a wavelength.
Then how would it differ?
How about between the
first and the second?
We send the first and the second where
they exactly cancel and get zero.
But Ah, there are three in the
first and four in the second,
right.
So you got,
you got plus three but minus four.
How about the next one?
Speak up gang
plus two and the last one minus
one and what's the net scattering?
Zero.
Okay,
so you can see how this is a neat
trick to work. If you can see in the,
in the pattern a of planes which
will contain the electrons,
then you can figure out a particular
direction how strong the scattering would
be.
Now we're going to do an experiment
and it requires the room to be dark.
And so I'm going to start turning the
lights off and asked Philip to get into
position to do stuff in
the dark here. Uh, okay.
And turn this one off.
Okay.
Now I'll show you first what we're
going to do. So pull out the, uh,
the little thing there.
And there's a laser that's focused
right here, but it's too bright,
right? Cause the other things
we're going to see are very dim,
which is why we have turned the lights
off. So I'm going to put this black tube,
there was a little hole in the end.
Hopefully I can get it physician.
So most of the laser will go inside
here and we won't see it very well.
Positions, right? It's a moving
target, so it's not so easy.
Okay.
Now,
so here's the view from the ceiling.
There's the screen and this laser is
coming from the back of the room and
hitting the screen right here.
Okay.
Now what Philip is going to do is
put things called defraction masks,
which are just slides 35 millimeter
slides and he's going to put them in the
path of the light.
And this is,
and that's the distance from
Phillip to here is 10.6 meters.
Okay. I measured it. Okay. And
so put,
put it on the first slide please.
And see this,
those are all deflections
at different angles.
And what's doing the scattering
is a slide that looks like this.
Okay. A bunch of jail window. Right.
Okay.
So it's what it's giving is a row of dots.
Now I'm going to ask Phillip to
do two things here. First, uh,
first rotate the slide around this axis.
So rotate it like this. What do you
think will happen? Right? You see, right,
it's perpendicular to the direction of
the row of spots is perpendicular to the
direction of the lines. Okay? And now I'm
going to ask him to do something else.
I'm going to ask them to
twist the slide like this,
which changes the effective
distance between the these.
And notice what happens is he
makes them closer twisting.
It makes them look closer together,
right? What happens to the spots?
Does that surprise you?
That's that reciprocal relationship.
When things get closer
together, the angles get, okay.
Now things are going to get a darker here.
So I'm going to do some things
and that out and also get the room light.
Uh, well no, I, I want to show
you something here first. Okay.
So I'm going to show
you what I'm going to,
what the masks are going to be and then
we'll show you the effect from the masks.
Okay. So the next, uh, so here's a
question for you to work for homework.
What is the spacing of the
lines on Phillips slide?
How far the bars in the jail window
apart on that slide in order to give a
spacing, uh, here, oh, I did the wrong
premature with that.
In order to get that 10.8 spacing,
pen 0.8 centimeter spacing here at a
distance of 10.6 meters with 63 nanometer
wavelength light.
Okay.
You can use that to find the distance
between the bars on his slide.
And I want you to do that
cause if you can do it,
then you understand how this works. Okay.
But the next one he's going to show,
not yet,
but he'll put it in,
is one that's a similar
spacing but of pairs of lines.
There's a pattern being
repeated pairs of lines. Okay.
And then he's going to go to a
whole bunch of hexagons of dots,
which we will call benzene,
but it's not exactly like benzine would
be a benzene gas because they're all
oriented exactly the same way.
Right? So it's oriented benzene.
That's the next one
we're going to look at.
And then we're going to look at this one,
which is also oriented benzene.
Can you see the difference in the pattern
between the one on the top and the one
on the bottom?
Those red lines are a hint
in the bottom there all pairs of
hexagons that are distributed randomly.
We're at the top of their
individual ones now.
Then he's going to show you this one.
How is that different?
It's core tenets of hexagons. And
finally he's going to show you this one,
which is a crystal of hexagons.
And in a crystal,
they will truly would be oriented.
Okay. And then we're going to the, the,
uh,
the PS,
the Raci stoss at the end of this sound
and light show is going to be that.
You know what that is?
It's a light bulb filament that he's
going to hold up in the path of this.
So a helix, okay, now,
now we're ready to do
the trick. So we'll, uh,
we'll do that and do this.
And if you had a laptop open, you'll
need to close it because we've got it.
It's not very bright.
So we have to make it as dark as possible.
And I have to find my way back
there and close my laptop.
Okay, you're ready to fill up. Okay,
so first it's got to
be pairs of jail bars.
So how does it look different
from what we saw before?
It's the same kind of dots,
but their intensity is modulated.
They're not just evenly just,
they're not just all the same or slowly
dying away as you move out to right or
left, they come in a pattern.
Okay. Now let's do the next one.
This is the one that's, that's
uh, that's benzene, right,
but randomly random collection of benzene.
So how would you describe that?
It looks like the snowflake. I got
gotta. Oh, my laptop has, come on,
go figure putting things to cover
the lights up here in a wallet.
Okay. Okay, so it's a snowflake.
Now we're going to look at
pairs of pairs of benzenes.
How is it different still the snowflake,
but their bars across it.
Everybody see that?
Can we stop the green blink back
there or puts up in across it?
That's good. Okay. Now we're
going to do quartets of benzenes.
How's that look?
How would you describe that?
It's now got bars going
in both directions, right?
Not just horizontal Lloyd, but also
vertical. They're actually vertical.
I'm not quite, okay. Now
the lattice of Benzenes
in that great.
So it takes the same,
it's the same underlying pattern,
the snowflake,
but it concentrates all the light.
That would have been spread out into very,
very fine points.
Remember when you,
when it was just payers,
we put bars across but it was the same
amount of light coming out so that it got
focused sort of. And when we have a
whole lot as he gets fabulously focused,
I can see things quite far out from the
middle here because I'm so close to the
screen, I'll hold my hand up
but you can't see my hand.
They go way out. So that's
what, that's what a crystal is.
The crystal picks the same underlying
pattern that comes from the molecule and
focuses it into intense points at many,
many angles and that,
so it's like looking at the
scattering from a single molecule,
but looking at it through a peg board.
Do you have, you know what a pegboard,
is it a tool shop?
You use the put put a pegboard up as a
piece of a mason EIT or something that
had holes in it.
It regularly and you could put little
hooks in it to hang your hammer in your
saw and whatnot.
So it's as if you have,
you're looking through such a
pegboard at that underlying pattern.
And now we're ready for the PS,
the resistance, which is the,
the light bulb filament,
which is hard to see.
This is why we really needed the lights
out we needed for the snowflake too,
because it was so, so what do you
see from a light bulb filament?
You see an x,
right?
People in the back seat,
the x and their dots
along the arms of the x.
Okay,
so that does it.
You can open your laptops
again now and we'll,
uh,
try to get some lights back on.
Sorry for straining your eyes.
This one up. Sorry. Here we go.
Okay. So there's, there is the scattering
from these things and we can, uh, now,
so let's try to, oops. Uh,
let's try to understand it.
So this was the slide with randomly
positioned but oriented benzenes.
It turns out that random positioning
generates the same diffraction as a single
pattern, but gives it more intensity.
If we just put one hexagon there,
you wouldn't have seen enough from it.
Okay?
So here's the pattern you
got from isolated benzenes,
which is that snowflake pattern,
right?
And when we, uh, when we
had a lattice made to those,
you saw the same underlying pattern,
but only at little,
only at regularly spaced spots that had
to do with how far apart the hexagons
were from one another, right? Uh, and uh,
and much more intense because all the
light that would be scattered all over the
screen here is focused in those
little dots. Okay? Now the,
and the thing that generated
this snowflake was benzene
or what we're calling
benzene, the hexagon. Okay.
Now can you see what we
need in order to understand,
what do you look for in order to see what
directions we'll give you a scattering.
Ah, sorry, I was having
so much fun. We went over.
So we'll talk about this next time.
Thanks.